welcome to this exciting tutorial on
dictionaries in Python if you are new to
Python Programming this video is for you
dictionaries are an essential part of
the language that you will use over and
over again in your coding adventures and
for the more experienced python
programmers out there this video will
refresh your knowledge and give you some
neat new tricks to use in your code so
what exactly is a dictionary it's a data
structure in Python that allows you to
map one set of values to another set of
values in other words you can use a
dictionary to associate a key a unique
identifier with the value the data
associated with that key this makes
dictionaries extremely powerful and
versatile and they are used in a wide
variety of applications from web
development to data analysis but that's
not all dictionaries are also super fun
to use did you know that dictionaries
allows for seamless use of alternate
data types like strings and booleans
that means you can store and retrieve
data quickly and efficiently without the
need for time consuming type conversions
before we dive deeper into dictionaries
in Python if you enjoy watching these
videos and find them interesting please
subscribe to our Channel because we
bring the best videos for you daily also
hit the Bell icon to get notified
whenever we drop a new video if you are
one of the aspiring data scientists
looking for online training and
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
careers with data science by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learn skeltec postgraduate
program in data science in collaboration
with IBM the course link is mentioned in
the description box below that will link
it to the course page where you can find
a complete overview of the program being
offered so whether you are just starting
out with python or you are an
experienced programmer this tutorial has
something for everyone dictionaries are
an essential part of the language and
learning how to use them will make your
programming life a whole lot easier
let's get started dictionaries are
another type of composite data type in
Python there are also a collection of
objects but much like tuples and lists
and like lists they are also mutable
Dynamic and can be nested however a key
difference and property of dictionaries
is that they are unordered items and
dictionaries are paired using keys
unlike enlisted tuples where the objects
are assigned numerical indexes to define
a dictionary we use curly braces each
key value pair in this dictionary in a
dictionary is separated using commas and
the key and values themselves in a pair
are separated using a colon let's look
at an example this is a dictionary where
I have three key value pairs as you can
see they have been separated by colons
and each repair themselves are separated
by commas and these are enclosed in
curly braces to define the whole
dictionary in this example these are the
keys banana apple and grape and their
respective values are yellow red and
green so this is very important
important that in this particular data
type we have what we call a key and that
key is assigned a value and we can have
multiple such pairings and we have three
such pairs in this particular example
another example or the or another type
of way to define a dictionary is using
the dict function this is how we use it
as you can see I have inputted two value
or two object tuples this is a tuple
this is atiopal and this is 80 opal and
when I use it in a dict function when I
place it within a list what python will
do is it will consider the first element
of each Tuple as a key and the second
element of each Tuple as its respective
value now if I check what's in D as you
can see the key banana has a value
yellow the key apple has a value red the
key grape has a value green so this is
another way of defining dictionaries an
important note over here is that
the the objects that we use for Keys
have to be of an immutable data type so
we cannot use for example lists uh as an
example of keys but we can use say
integers or strings for our dictionary
Keys also Keys have to be unique when it
comes to a dictionary you cannot have
two different keys with uh or should I
say the same key having two different
values you can have only one key and
that one key will have a unique value
assigned to it duplicate keys are not
allowed however when we speak about
values we have no such restrictions you
can have immutable or an immutable data
type as a value in a dictionary and you
can have duplicates as well so if I
created a dictionary with a key say
banana and if I give if I associate it
with it
a value green I cannot create another
key banana and Associate a value yellow
let's see what happens when I actually
do this if you actually see what has
happened here is python has considered
the second case so it's it first looks
at the first pair it goes okay so my
dictionary has a key banana with a value
green but right after it it sees another
key banana with a value yellow so it
overwrites my first key banana with the
second key and it overwrites the first
value green with the second value and we
essentially get one key banana with the
second value yellow so obviously this is
python does this to avoid duplicacies
however if I created a dictionary with a
key banana again if I created I'll give
it a value yellow or say green if I
created another
key and if I give this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not nothing special will happen in
this case because values do not have to
follow such rules let's speak or let's
see certain dictionary operation
operations and functions now so let's uh
bring back our original dictionary which
we had created earlier with the three
pairs all right so what if I wanted to
we can use keys to essentially do these
operations and functions let's see what
happens when we so much like how we use
sequence how we use indexes in example
of sequences we use Keys when it comes
to dictionary so let's see what happens
when we use a key over here so we as we
know banana is a key in this dictionary
let's see what happens when we do where
we give this command it actually gives
the value associated with that key which
is yellow what if we wanted to change a
particular value Associated to a
particular key I would give I would do
this I would give the key and assign it
uh the value that I want to change it
with all right now if I check my
dictionary you can see the key banana no
more has yellow value but the value gold
what if I wanted to add a new pair you
know a new key with a new value
completely I would do it pretty much the
same same way as I did in the previous
step I would
um essentially write my new key whatever
I wanted say if I wanted a new key
called watermelon I would assign it a
value red and now if I check my
dictionary at the end of the dictionary
you will see that my new key pair key
value pair has been added watermelon red
as you can see over here now what if I
wanted to remove if I wanted to remove a
key value pair from my dictionary I can
use the delete function which is called
by using this the Del function now how
do I do it see if I want to remove the
key value Apple in Red so all I have to
do is do del d and within square
brackets I have to only mention the key
I don't even need to mention the value
just the key so you can probably draw
parallels in how we use indexes when it
comes to lists and tuples and even
strings and how we use Keys when it
comes to dictionaries they are quite
similar so if I did this and if I oops I
think red is actually not a key as you
can see red is a value my key is Apple
actually it's not red it's apple as you
can see now if I see my dictionary the
key apple and its value red has been
removed so these are some of the
operation questions that we can do for
dictionaries using keys what if we
wanted to use certain inbuilt functions
that are associated with dictionaries
well some of the examples are as follows
there is a get function when we use the
get function all we have to do is enter
a key inside the parenthesis and it will
get the value associated with that key
so if I gave the key grip let's see what
value is associated with it as you can
see it's green there is also a function
called items that Returns the key and
value pairs in our dictionary as a list
of two object tuples where the first
object is the key and the second object
is the Tuple so let's see what it does
as you can see it gave me a list and in
this list the objects inside the list
are two object tuples where the first
object is always the key and the second
is the value and and it's the same for
each of the tuples so this is what items
function does let's see what uh the next
so the next function is Keys let's see
what the keys function does as you can
see it returns a list of all the unique
Keys within our list I mean within our
dictionary similarly we can there is a
function for values as well and as you
can see it returns all of the different
values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say a
particular value say I had another key
where its value was green again so I
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the pop function in list it
gives us the last entered key value pair
that is present in our dictionary so the
last centered pair was watermelon key
watermelon with the value red and that's
what has popped out when we give this
function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so say
if I had a dictionary let's say I'm
creating a dictionary using the dict
function where I have say some key
called key V so as I had mentioned I
will use two object tuples in this case
and say give this also a value green all
right and another pair would be say
mango and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called kiwi with value green and
another key mango with a value yellow
and I already have a dictionary D with
uh these values all right now if I want
to merge these two dictionaries I can
use the update function what I do is say
if I want to merge D with X or x with d
only the ordering will change and that
doesn't really matter when it comes to
dictionaries so if I want to merge D
with X I use D update and then inside it
I put my target dictionary now when I
check what's in D I have the the
dictionary X and its key value pairs uh
merged inside my original Dictionary d
as you can see I have my original ones
here and I have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function
with that we have reached the end of
this dictionary is in Python tutorial if
you have any questions please feel free
to comment and we'll have it answered
for you as soon as possible until next
time thank you for watching stay safe
keep learning and get ahead staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign